I read this interesting commentary a little while ago on a statement by Christ
in the New Testament,
and the statement generally interpreted is that the meek shall inherit the
earth,
but I was looking up the multiple translations of the word Meek,
and meek is actually derived from a Greek word,
of course,
because the Bible,
at least some of the original forms of the Bible were in Greek.
Um,
and that word didn't exactly mean meek.
It meant something like
those who have weapons and the ability to use them,
but cert,
but determined to keep the machines will inherit the world.
And that means that people who are capable of force,
let's say,
but decided not to use it,
are in the proper moral position.